so I did water towers gonna get me start
our work our oh really don't even you
like wonder towers - or please I don't
want to feel alone then please say yes
[Music]
so when you talk about water towers yes
you have to be specific because if you
live in New York City where did that
water tower means only one thing and
that's the the vessel that holds water
on the top of your building but most
people I think when you they hear water
tower they think of the water tower
that's in the center of their town
that's true
and if you came at the right time and
Twilight and you're not quite fully
there mm-hmm it looks like they all
almost look like they landed from Mars
right aliens coming down in fact
cheering the broadcast of War of the
Worlds there are people thinking it's
real and they were described as having
these rich you know and so people were
shooting water towers who didn't water
towers yeah thinking that that was what
was being described anyhow so it's kind
of cool actually water towers are
interesting because it gives you water
pressure without electricity provided
it's full of order
all right all right but how do you get
the water up there you got to pump it
mmm Lord it doesn't get there by itself
okay now I get to get water up to the
top of your roof you got to pump it that
takes electricity so here's what happens
you pump the water up to the tower up
now there's a blackout you still have
water until that tank empties right then
you don't have water cuz you have
gravity as long as you have grab there's
only chefwell gravity to pull the water
from you have it right so basically if
electricity goes out quickly fill up
everything with water and then it'll be
gone and then you could you don't have
to be stank you know the next day so now
here's the interesting question if you
got to pump the water up to the tower
right why not just pump the water
straight to the people's apartments in
the building Oh cuz they might not need
it in that moment plus plus you want
enough water at any given instant to
accommodate everybody if everybody wants
to take a shower they can do it right
because all the water is right in this
run in that one thing but if you
therefore everybody would have to have a
pump and what's the point of that right
right so it has that efficiency okay see
I like water towers even more there's
another thing
have you ever noticed the buckles that
go around the water tower that holds
them together like little metal rods the
middle row all the way around yeah have
you ever noticed though yes I have have
you ever thought about really let's put
the water
into three levels okay top middle and
bottom okay that would be a good three
so you can ask what is the weight of the
water of that top third its whatever it
is right okay call it 500 pounds five an
impact so now I put a little buckle
around that right okay right at that
spot
let me go to the bottom of that well now
what is the weight of water at that
point well it's the top part I've
hundred plus it's a thousand pounds well
if for the 500 at the bottom yeah yes
all right so if one one of these hoops
is the right strength to hold 500 pounds
right then that what I I need more than
one hoop to hold it down here yeah I
need to right if one could hold five I
did that two will hold this out now I'm
at the bottom I have fired up refinery I
got 1,500 pounds pressing down at the
bottom right I need three of those hoops
got in okay go look at the water towers
on the tops of buildings the hoops get
closer and closer as you get to the bar
as you get to the bottom just because of
this fact the water gets heavy that is
more than you ever wanted to know about
I know if they're equally spaced the
person didn't know what they were doing
and you should not move into that
building because they bought the base of
the water tower would not be a
structurally sound as the upper portions
and that's you know that's where the
stuff goes bad
you better have flood insurance if that
happens yeah wow that is so cool water
towers lured into physics no bit of
little bit electricity happening oh well
I think I thought if a building is in
Manhattan is lower than about six
storeys uh-huh does it need a water
tower alright mmm because wait let me
guess
because you can get the water to every
apartment just through the regular
pressure of a pump yes no it's not a
pump not a problem it's the height of
the reservoir that's feeding Manhattan
has that elevation above Manhattan
that's yeah so the blood pressure is
already there grab the waterfalls from
the reservoir into your faucet over that
height and you know something
the ancient Romans knew that the
aqueducts were built on that core duct
some of which pieces of which are still
standing yeah was a channel that fed the
lake well whatever was their water
supply which is at a higher elevation
than Rome and they scooped up that water
and the water just go down all by
yourself no pump necessary
well they don't build those apple ducks
like they used to no sir it's still
standing yeah but stuff here falling
down that built 10 years ago and that's
up for 2,000 years God hey it just met
the mayor of Rome of problem spend too
much money building it if your
structures outlive your civilizations by
2,000 years yeah you over bill probably
over there all right there you go who
knew there was so much to learn about
water towers so next time I wash my
hands I'm gonna remember how far that
water had to travel into my building yes
right by the way I never washed my hands
okay if you're interested in learning
more about hydrostatic pressure
why are everyday appliances are
constructed in certain ways or how we
use gravity to our advantage every
single day you should check out
brilliant whether you're into
superpowers or well of course that's
superpowers or a lifelong learner or
just somebody who is naturally curious
or if you're weirdly into water towers
like he is brilliant will help you
master concepts in math science and
engineering through solving fun
challenging problems I'm looking through
the outside-the-box geometry course
these beautiful geometry problems have
such amazing solutions that I want to
read the solutions even if I got it
correct it's so much fun I don't even
realize that I'm learning this is
seriously amazing stuff and as a bonus
to Startalk Brewers the first 78 that go
to brilliant a quark slash star talks to
pull that number out er you know what
they're right there
you'll get 20% off an annual
subscription which helps you think like
a scientist you know where I pull
numbers on where thin space that's the
finished dinner there's no atmosphere
you not a man he pulls his number they
go forever you want to see more videos
from star talk hit the subscribe par and
click the little Bell button to get
notifications every single time that we
upload a video and give us a like or a
comment to express your
passion okay so make sure that you check
us out and make sure that you check him
out because every time you do he's gonna
tell you the same thing I will tell you
to keep looking up
[Music]